♪ ♪
>> Sean: AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS ARE IN A
STATE OF PANIC.
THERE FAR LEFT IDEOLOGY IS
UNPOPULAR, THEIR POLICIES ARE A
DISASTER.
THEIR PRESIDENT, WELL, MOST
AMERICANS AGREE IS MENTALLY
UNFIT, THEIR VICE PRESIDENT IS
INCOMPETENT, THEIR POLL NUMBERS
ARE WORSE THAN EVER, AND NOW
THEIR PRECIOUS TWITTER IS UNDER
NEW OWNERSHIP.
NOW THE DAYS OF ARBITRARILY
BANNING OR CENSORING SPEECH
APPEARS TO BE OVER.
FREE SPEECH, ACCORDING TO
ELON MUSK, IS COMING TO TWITTER
AND HIDING IN THEIR IVORY TOWER
FROM AMERICA'S EVER SO FRAGILE
LEFT LIBERALS, THEY CAN'T SEEM
TO HANDLE IT EMOTIONALLY, IT'S
KIND OF FUNNY.
NOTORIOUS BROUGHT A
ELIZABETH WARREN CALLED IT "DAN"
AND THEN THREATENED --
JUST STEAL IT.
SOCIALIST SENATOR ED MARKEY WAS
OPENLY WORRIED ABOUT ELON'S
DANGEROUS INFLUENCE OF THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF
TWEETING "I AM CONCERNED ELON'S
PERSONAL VIEWS, THE VIEWS WILL
STOP THE FIGHT AGAINST
DISINFORMATION ON SOCIAL MEDIA."
THE BIGGEST LIAR IN THE COUNTRY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, NO ONE IN
AMERICA HAS PUSHED MORE
DISINFORMATION THAN HIM.
NOW HE FREQUENTLY CLAIMS THERE
WAS DIRECT AND AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE A LIE AND
A HOAX AND A CONSPIRACY THEORY
THAT HE SOLD TO AMERICA FOR
YEARS.
NOW TO THIS DAY, ADAM SCHIFF, HE
CONTINUES TO CAST DOUBTS ON THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE 2016 ELECTION.
ADAM SCHIFF IS NOT WORRIED
AMERICANS WILL BE EXPOSED TO
DISINFORMATION.
NO, HE IS ACTUALLY WORRIED THEY
WILL BE EXPOSED TO SOMETHING
CALLED THE TRUTH, SOMETHING HE
IS NOT REALLY FAMILIAR WITH.
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE HUNTER BIDEN'S
VERY REAL LAPTOP FROM HELL.
IN 2020, TWITTER COMPLETELY
CENSORED "NEW YORK POST" AND
THEIR BOMBSHELL REPORT ON THE
LAPTOP JUST WEEKS BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THEY EVEN BANNED PRIVATE
MESSAGES LINKING TO THE STORY.
AND THEY LOCKED TWITTER ACCOUNTS
OF AMERICA'S OLDEST DAILY
NEWSPAPER APPEARED AT THE TIME,
TWITTER CLAIMED THE POST
VIOLATED THEIR HACKED MATERIALSE
MATERIALS WERE NOT HACKED.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE THE
MATERIAL WAS HACKED IN ANY WAY
SHAPE MANNER OR FORM.
IN REALITY, TWITTER BLOCKED THE
REPORT FOR ONE REASON AND ONE
REASON ONLY, TO PROTECT
JOE BIDEN.
PERIOD.
WHAT DID I CALL IT?
THAT'S RIGHT, THE CANDIDATE
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
YESTERDAY, TWITTER'S NEW OWNER
TWEETED "SUSPENDING THE TWITTER
ACCOUNT OF A MAJOR NEWS
ORGANIZATION FOR PUBLISHING A
TRUTHFUL STORY WAS OBVIOUSLY
INCREDIBLY INAPPROPRIATE" AND
NOW SOMETHING ELSE INAPPROPRIATE
APPEARS TO BE GOING ON AT
TWITTER.
SHORTLY AFTER ELON'S SUCCESSFUL
BID TO BUY THE SOCIAL MEDIA
GIANT, CONSERVATIVES ON THE
PLATFORM COME ALL OF A SUDDEN
COME OUT OF NOWHERE, ENJOYED A
MASSIVE BUMP IN FOLLOWERS AND
INTERACTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN JUST TWO DAYS,
DONALD TRUMP JR., WOW,
MAGICALLY, HE GOT 200,000 NEW
FOLLOWERS.
THAT IS ROUGHLY 2000% INCREASE
DAILY.
WOW.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF TWITTER
EMPLOYEES LIFTED A BROAD
ANTI-CONSERVATIVE, ANTI-TRUMP
SHADOW BAN, WHICH WE ALL KNEW
WAS TAKING PLACE ANYWAY IN AN
EFFORT TO COVER THEIR TRACKS
BEFORE THE NEW BOSS TAKES OVER.
NOW TWITTER CLAIMS THERE IS
NOTHING NEFARIOUS AT PLAY HERE
BUT THEY SAID THAT ALL BEFORE.
WE KNOW THE CURRENT EXECUTIVES
AT TWITTER ARE FAR LEFT
POLITICAL HACKS.
WE HAVE WITNESSED THEIR
DISHONEST, THEY'RE DEEPLY BIASED
GATEKEEPING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, BUT HOPEFULLY THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE.
AND STORIES ABOUT THE BIDEN
FAMILIES VERY REAL CORRUPTION
MIGHT EVEN BE ALLOWED TO TREND
SOMETIMES.
NOW LIKE THIS VERY INTERESTING
DEVELOPMENT, ACCORDING TO NEWLY
UNCOVERED EMAILS, HUNTER BIDEN
TRASHED BILL CLINTON AND
EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
HE REFERRED TO CLINTON AS AN
ANTI-HOLE WHO LOOKS LIKE
ADAM SCHIFF AND ALSO REFERRED TO
CLINTON AIDES AS PETTY, GREEDY,
LOW RENT, FOR GETTING PAID BY
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
ACCORDING TO HUNTER, THE ONLY
CLASSY WAY TO MAKE MONEY IS TO
SELL OUT YOUR FATHER'S OFFICE.
COMMUNIST CHINESE, RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS, UKRAINE, AVOID PAYING
TAXES, AND THEN SPEND MILLIONS
ON CRACK COCAINE,, AND LOW
MILEAGE LEASES ON EXOTIC CARS.
ALL WHILE SAVING 10% FOR THE BIG
GUY.
THAT'S RIGHT, PRESIDENT JOEY.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE IN MY
MONOLOGUE IN JUST A MINUTE BUT
FIRST, HERE NOW WITH THE
REACTION IS LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY.
SENATOR, I DON'T KNOW, I DO FOR
HOURS ON AIR A DAY AND FROM WHAT
I UNDERSTOOD, ALL THESE
CONSERVATIVES, LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY WERE
CANCELED ON PLATFORMS LIKE
TWITTER AND INSTAGRAM AND
FACEBOOK, ET CETERA.
WE KNOW SHADOW BANNING HAS TAKEN
PLACE ON MANY OF THESE
PLATFORMS.
AND NOW, ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE
LEFT IS FEARFUL THAT INFORMATION
MIGHT NOT BE FLOWING FREELY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT THEY REALLY
FEAR IS THE FREE FLOW OF
INFORMATION.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, SEAN, THE TWITTER
EXECUTIVES, THEY ARE VERY UPSET
THIS WEEK.
I THINK MR. MUSK MET A COUPLE OF
THEM CRY.
I'M SURE MORE THAN A COUPLE HAVE
GONE OUT AND ALREADY BOUGHT AN
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT PONY.
BUT HERE IS WHAT IS GOING ON.
TWITTER IS RUN BY WOKERS.
WOKERS REPRESENT THE RIGHT WING
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WOKERS AS I SAID BEFORE, EASY TO
RECOGNIZE, MOST OF THEM EAT FOOD
ONLY FIT FOR RATS.
HE ALMOST ALWAYS ENTER A
SWIMMING POOL BY THE STAIRS.
THEY ALSO DON'T BELIEVE IN
FREE SPEECH.
I DO.
WHICH MEANS I RESPECT THE RIGHT
OF THE WOKERS TO HAVE THEIR
OPINION BUT I HAVE AN OPINION
AND HERE IS MINE, EXPERIENCE
SHOWS THAT THE WOKERS WHO RUN
TWITTER ARE INTOLERANT, THEY ARE
IN TEMPERAMENT, THEY ARE
FOOLISH, THEY ARE ON THOUGHTFUL.
EXPERIENCE SHOWS THAT THE WOKER
EXECUTIVES WHO RUN TWITTER, THEY
DON'T RESPECT ANY OPINION BUT
THEIR OWN AND THEY CENSOR ALL
OTHERS.
THEY ARE ALSO NOT NORMAL
AMERICANS.
THEY BELIEVE, FOR EXAMPLE, THAT
KIDS SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHANGE
THEIR GENDER AT RECESS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT COPS ARE MORE
OF A PROBLEM THAN CRIMINALS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES IN FLORIDA HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO TALK TO
5-YEAR-OLDS ABOUT SEXUALITY.
NOW, AGAIN, THAT'S ALL OKAY,
THIS IS AMERICA, YOU CAN BELIEVE
WHAT YOU WANT, BUT THEY CAN'T
AND SHOULDN'T CENSOR THOSE
ON TWITTER WHO DISAGREE WITH
THEM.
MR. MUSK HAS BOUGHT IT AND
HERE'S WHAT I THINK YOU SHOULD
DO, I THINK YOU SHOULD CALL IN
ALL THE WOKE TWITTER EXECUTIVES
AND SAY FOLKS, WE ARE GOING TO
START RESPECTING FREE SPEECH.
I PROMISE YOU AT LEAST ONE WILL
SAY MR. MUSK, WE CAN'T DO THAT
AND I WON'T DO THAT.
THAT'S THE ONE MR. MUSK SHOULD
FIRE.
>> Sean: TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER.
I THINK YOU SHOULD CLEAN OUT THE
WHOLE ORGANIZATION.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD ABOUT
THE ONE LAWYER, APPARENTLY BROKE
DOWN CRYING OVER THE FACT THAT
ELON MUSK TOOK OVER.
ELON MUSK SAID SOMETHING THAT
REALLY STRUCK ME, SENATOR, HE
SAID FOR ALL MY CRITICS OUT
THERE, I HOPE YOU STAY
ON TWITTER SO YOU CAN LEARN WHAT
FREE SPEECH IS ALL ABOUT.
BASICALLY INVITING THEM TO
CRITICIZE HIM.
NOW, WHAT'S AMAZING IS YOU HAVE
ALL OF THESE LEFT-WING
NEWSPEOPLE AND ALL OF THESE
LEFT-WING POLITICIANS SAYING
WELL COME HANG ON, A CANDIDATE
OR A POLITICIAN MIGHT GET BANNED
OR THROTTLED BACK, AND I'M
THINKING, DO YOU NOT KNOW WHAT
HAS BEEN HAPPENING OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS?
HOW DO THEY BIFURCATE THEIR
BRAINS INTO THINKING IT IS OKAY
TO DO IT TO A CONSERVATIVE BUT
ONLY THE THREAT OF IT HAPPENING
TO THEM FINALLY WAKES THEM UP TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF FREEDOM OF
SPEECH?
>> WELL, THE IRONY IS RICH.
LOOK, WHAT MUSK IS PROPOSING IS
NOTHING EXTRAORDINARY.
HE JUST BELIEVES IN FREE SPEECH.
NOW WHAT DOES FREE-SPEECH MEAN?
IT MEANS YOU ARE NOT FREE UNLESS
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF.
IT MEANS YOU ARE NOT FREE UNLESS
YOU CAN SAY WHAT YOU THINK.
HE IS NOT TELLING THE WOKERS
THAT THEY CAN'T EXPRESS THEIR
OPINION ON TWITTER.
WHAT HE IS SAYING TO THE WOKERS,
THE ONES WHO RUN TWITTER, YOU
CAN'T CENSOR POINTS OF VIEW THAT
YOU DISAGREE WITH.
THAT IS THE WAY AMERICA WORKS.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE WAY THAT
TWITTER HAS WORKED.
AND I THINK IT IS VERY
REFRESHING.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU,
SHOULD THERE BE -- OBVIOUSLY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A LIMIT, NOBODY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE A
PHYSICAL THREAT AGAINST
SOMEBODY.
>> OF COURSE, NO HATE SPEECH.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T MAKE A
PHYSICAL THREAT, THAT IS ILLEGAL
ANYWAY.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU DO
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO HAVE A
FREEDOM OF SPEECH PLATFORM, I
MEAN, ANY REASONABLE PERSON WITH
A CONSCIENCE AND A SOUL DEPLORES
REAL RACISM, AND DEPLORES REAL
ANTI-SEMITISM.
DO YOU LET THOSE PEOPLE SAY WHAT
THEY WANT AND ASSUME THAT THE
FREE MARKET WILL JUST KIND OF
WEED THEM OUT AND PEOPLE WON'T
PAY ATTENTION TO THEM?
OR SHOULD THERE BE SOME
STANDARDS?
THAT GETS A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED.
>> WELL, YOU SHOULDN'T ALLOW
HATE SPEECH.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO TRUST
AMERICANS.
YOU'VE GOT TO TRUST PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO THINK FOR THEMSELVES.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF.
THE WOKERS, PROBABLY THE WOKER
EXECUTIVES WHO RUN TWITTER, THEY
BELIEVE THAT ALL WHITE PEOPLE
ARE RACIST.
NOW, I THINK THEY WANT TO, AS
SILLY AS THAT IS, THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT ON THEIR OWN
PLATFORM, BUT PEOPLE WHO
DISAGREE WITH THEM SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DISAGREE.
AND SAY NO, THAT IN AND OF
ITSELF IS A HIGHER FORM OF
RACISM AND HERE IS WHY.
THAT IS CALLED THE FREE EXCHANGE
OF IDEAS.
AND THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE
ON TWITTER.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
INCLUDING THE WOKER EXECUTIVES
WHO RUN IT.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE SO UPSET.
AND I DON'T -- I HOPE, I DON'T
THINK MR. MUSK IS GOING TO BACK
DOWN.
MY ADVICE TO MY FRIENDS AT
TWITTER WHO ARE RUNNING THE
PLACE IS LOW, THERE IS A NEW
SHERIFF IN TOWN.
GO FILL OUT A HURT FEELINGS
REPORT, BUT THINGS ARE GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT.
>> Sean: [LAUGHS]
SET OUT A HURT FEELINGS -- I
DON'T KNOW WHY COME EVERY TIME
YOU SAY THE WORD "WOKER," IT
CRACKS ME UP AND MAKES ME LAUGH.
THEY ARE OUT THERE.
SENATOR, WE ARE WATCHING YOUR
RACE, YOU ARE SO POPULAR IN
LOUISIANA COME I DON'T THINK
THERE ARE EVEN MANY WOKERS THAT
LIVE IN LOUISIANA.
>> WE HAVE SOME WOKERS, BUT
LOOK, THEY ARE ENTITLED TO THEIR
OPINION.
HOW CAN I PUT THIS?
>> Sean: [LAUGHS]
>> I HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
I JUST DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
I SAY WHAT I THINK.
AND I HAVE THAT RIGHT AS AN
AMERICAN, AND IF YOU DISAGREE
WITH ME, YOU ARE ENTITLED TO
DISAGREE WITH ME.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES AMERICA WORK.
>> Sean: I LOVE THAT.
>> AND THAT IS WHAT TWITTER HAS
BEEN MISSING.
>> Sean: I HAVE THE RIGHT BUT
I CHOOSE NOT TO.
>> HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT BUT I DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY.
>> Sean: I DON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY, EITHER.
>> I'VE NOTICED.
>> Sean: SENATOR KENNEDY,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
IT IS NO SECRET BIDEN'S POLL
NUMBERS ARE HISTORICALLY BAD,
QUINNIPIAC AND I MET 43%
APPROVAL RATING.
EVEN INTO DEEP BLUE SPATE STATES
LIKE OREGON, NEW MEXICO, BIDEN S
UNDERWATER ANTEDATED FOUR NEW
POLLS HAVE BIDEN DOWN BY DOUBLE
DIGITS NATIONWIDE, INCLUDING
A 17-POINT DEFICIT IN RASMUSSEN.
A 13-POINT DEFICIT IN
"POLITICO," AND ACCORDING TO
GALLUP, RECORD-SETTING INFLATION
IS CONTRIBUTE INTO THESE
NUMBERS.
STILL, JOE IS NOT ATTEMPTING TO
PUMP AN ADDITIONAL $1.6 TRILLION
INTO THE ECONOMY IN ORDER TO PAY
OFF ALL STUDENT LOANS.
IN OTHER WORDS, BIDEN GETS HIS
WAY, THIS NEW PLAN, FORGET ABOUT
THE 40 YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION,
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES,
EVERYTHING COSTING MORE IN EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO, EVERY AMERICAN
FAMILY WILL NOW BE FORCED TO
SHOULDER A $13,000 BURDEN.
NOW, IT DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER
IF YOU DIDN'T EVEN GO TO
COLLEGE, OR IF YOU ALREADY PAID
OFF YOUR LOANS.
I PAID OFF MY LOANS.
$58.05, IT TOOK ME TEN YEARS TO
PAY IT OFF, I PAID EVERY PENNY.
MAYBE YOU WORKED YOUR WAY
THROUGH COLLEGE LIKE I WAS
WORKING MY WAY THROUGH COLLEGE
AT THE TIME TO MITIGATE THE
COSTS.
EVERYONE WILL HAVE TO PAY, SO
BIDEN CANOPIES HIS RADICAL NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIALIST BASE.
BY THE WAY, WHAT DOES THIS HAVE
TO DO WITH ANYTHING GREEN?
IT DOESN'T.
THE WHOLE GREEN NEW DEAL IS ONLY
ABOUT HIGHER ENERGY PRICES,
WHICH MAKES AMERICA LESS
COMPETITIVE AND HAS RESULTED IN
HIGHEST GAS PRICES WE HAVE EVER
HAD, A 41 YEAR HIGH I